exactly
how are you doing Michael nice to meet
you I recognize you from YouTube okay
thank you
not even a bit are you kidding me about
five five you can't beat me five two oh
no oh my God
okay ready in again
okay no don't trust him no Canada
I'll accept that that doesn't mean
anything
okay I don't get it what's happening
it's not in London
okay I understand every move you've made
so far
okay maybe not that except the last one
I didn't say that you were thinking
about it I'll go ahead
okay
Mike yeah you're gonna have to take away
your cards this isn't how I taught you
yeah I know I'm getting killed this
let's move on a planet
I still got you I'm not worried you know
that right
okay
I'm not I'm not so hungry
bro bro what are you doing you can take
this phone or you can take my Rooks no
I'm why in a way I can make you
go for it
thanks
I'm going to show you how much I admire
you which is Noah okay
that's okay
right it's okay I wouldn't worry about
this I don't have to wipe on my plan
that's it what am I going to worry about
exactly
I try to tell everybody everybody's
scared they don't understand the game
no mercy Mike none
that's okay you're doing very well I
don't know what it did oh son of a gun
he sees nothing isn't that a check
all right all right all right
I did the worst moves I could there
wasn't even it wasn't even good you
killed me